what are we going to call the david
pakman show coffee blends I've told you
that the plan is we are going to have to
blends and espresso blend and a drip
coffee blend whatever is your game you
will be able to take advantage of it I
am more of an espresso guy right now but
I used to be more into like french press
and drip coffee but we are going to make
both available we are going to be able
to deliver it to you ground however you
like or whole bean that's usually the
way I buy my coffee and I asked for
suggestions for names and I have a
couple things I want to play for you
first here is one voice mail related to
the naming of coffee take a listen to
this hey David I thought of an ironic
name for your coffee brew [ __ ] brew
and uh also um I'm wondering what kind
of roast are you gonna do for your drip
coffee is gonna be light roast medium
roast dark roast let me know that be
interested yeah it's gonna be slightly
more than medium I would call it like a
medium Plus roasts so here are some of
the coffee name ideas that have come in
so far which I'll put up on the screen
for you the roast of david pakman any
number of beans coffee freedom of the
press that's kind of interesting i kinda
like that Packman perk we've had a
couple of suggestions for progress oh
but I'm not big on it because there's a
Superbrand a name progresso but other
people said what about progress presso
like progressive an espresso okay that's
the interesting packmans virility roast
I like that as an homage as an homage to
your adopted American home how about
wicked roaster wicked good roast for one
of the coffee names yeah that's to
Boston centric I'm not that into that
free speech still drips I like that
ground in independence is a good one
progressive wake up call Patriot
repellent and lastly the stuff Alex
Jones is on uh my plan is keep sending
them in we've got a thread on our reddit
discussion forum at david pakman.com
slash reddit re d di t where you can up
comment on what your suggestions are for
the coffee names and you can also just
eat
male them in through our contact form at
david pakman.com or tweet them or put
them as comments to this youtube video
if you're watching on YouTube right now
next week we will do a final sort of
Assembly of the best ones will have
people vote and then we will decide on
what the names will be of the david
pakman show Koffee Rhodes roasts some
good ones here Pat a lot of these are
pretty clever yeah the funniest one may
be the one about Alex Jones the stuff
that Alex Jones a zombie which of course
we it it's not appropriate because this
is for our show yeah yeah no I that is
it's absolutely hilarious but we
probably should not reference other
individuals particularly with their own
shows and their own lines of products if
you've seen all the stuff we're selling
coffee which is so milquetoast compared
to Alex Jones actually sells like a male
virility enhancement and autism
prevention pills I mean anything you can
imagine almost Alex Jones is offering